We realized kind of intellectually
that to a certain degree
the way we think about this
planet whether that's water
on the planet,
life on the planet,
resources on the planet
we tend to think about it
from the very much
from the context of the surface,
of a 2 dimensional
pale blue dot.
And we realized that if
we could transform
our way of
thinking about the planet
to really
encompass the challenges
of three dimensional
science,
of thinking about what the subsurface
means in terms of
exploration for life,
understanding
subsurface life,
understanding water resources,
understanding the distribution
of other fluids
and gases
in the crust
that this could potentially
transform how we think
about the Earth but
most importantly as well
shed light then on
how we might think about exploring other worlds.
One thing that stood out
is that the surface
of Mars is a hostile place.
It is dry, cold, and it's bad radiation.
So where would you want to be
if you were
a microbe or any form of life?
You'd want to be underground
is the philosophy.
so that's what led me to
this partnership
with Barb
over the last couple of years because
here is where the expertise lies
to really understand
what a planet like Mars should
potentially behave like
and so we're transforming
the knowledge that we're learning from the
Earth and trying to fit that into the what
we understand about Mars.
There are not a lot of mechanisms to really
allow that much free-thinking and inter-disciplinarity,
and I think it is that, that CIFAR is going
to be particularly catalytic for us, to be
able to bring together people from extremely
different perspectives and then give them
that intellectual freedom to challenge each
other, challenge themselves to change the thinking.
Having life in this deep, long-term groundwater
on Earth is just opening up an entire field
of science that we did not know to exist 10
years ago.
And so what does it mean?
I think we're still trying to map that out,
but in terms of a whole aspect of biology
that was unknown and how it affects the surface,
how it affects the interior, how biology actually
works within these tight limits is really
the importance of what's going on with the
life underground.
[Music]